no hubiera querido ser aladino y que con
tan solo frotar una lámpara tuviéramos
la posibilidad de que el genio nos
concediera hacer todo lo que deseamos y
anhelamos en la vida
afortunadamente
esta lámpara lo más que puede hacer por
nosotros es sacar humo como aromaterapia
no creo que existan fórmulas
pero si creo que quien sostiene esa
lámpara es el único genio capaz de hacer
que esos sueños se vuelvan realidad
el día de hoy sólo quiero hablarles con
el corazón y compartirles un poco de mi
experiencia
el bruc menciona en su libro la puerta
abierta el yoyo y da un importantísimo
actor japonés sabía perfectamente cuando
estaba sobre el escenario y ejecutaba un
movimiento en donde estaban sus manos
sus ojos sus pies el ángulo de su cabeza
y no dejaban nada al azar
si bien creo que hay personas
situaciones que ocurren y están en el
lugar y momento exacto cuando uno tiene
una pasión detrás nunca se dejan nada al
azar
así en el estado de méxico pero viví de
los 13 a los 14 años en minatitlán
veracruz
la ciudad en la que aún permanece gran
parte de mi vida y de mi corazón
los mejores recuerdos mi madre mi
hermana el inicio del sueño
de niña quería ser actriz
y a pesar de las grandes dificultades
que había al no contar con escuelas
especializadas en una formación
artística
e imaginación y mi creatividad nunca
tuvieron límites
las primeras obras de teatro las monté
en el patio de una casa con grandes
amigas teniendo como único vestuario
capas hechas de toallas y de sábanas
siempre estaba construyendo
mi familia mi abuelo me bautizó como la
milusos porque no podía quedarme quieta
es que tomar cada oportunidad que se
presentó tocar en la banda de guerra
concursos de oratoria poesía basquetbol
futbol volibol alrededor de los 7 u 8
años
testigos decidieron formar un taller
para rescatar las tradiciones del son
jarocho y el zapateado
taller se llamaba el refugio del sol
y al final éramos tantos que terminamos
formando un grupo que se llamaba son un
montón
ahí
tuve mi primer conexión real con la
música
música que acompaña mis días hasta hoy y
me regresa al origen
primer renacimiento
s donde me sentía plena sobre el
escenario con un público frente a mí y
la adrenalina recorriendo todo mi cuerpo
y es un sentimiento que no volvía a
tener hasta mucho tiempo después
yo quería ser actriz
mi madre lo sabía
en un intento por acercarme a eso me
inscribió en el único centro de arte que
había en minatitlán donde pude acercarme
un poco a la creación con las máscaras
pero no era suficiente
hace poco una periodista me hizo una
pregunta que jamás hubiera esperado
él fue el consejo que te dio tu madre
cuando eras niña para hacerte hoy una
mujer fuerte
cabeza de revolución
mi madre más que darme un consejo me dio
un regalo
me dio la posibilidad con 14 años de
tomar mi vida y volar lejos de ella para
ir tras mis sueños
en algún punto ni ella ni yo sabemos
cómo pero hicimos un pacto termina la
secundaria y te vas a méjico a vivir con
tus abuelos
creo que mi madre en ese momento no
tenía idea ni yo
que me estaba cambiando la vida y dando
la posibilidad de nacer en mi auténtico
yo
así que con 14 años
con miedo terror a separarme de mi madre
y de mi hermana de dejar atrás a mis
amigos a mi música a mi estabilidad y mi
confort para ti
sin duda esa ha sido una de las
decisiones que más fuerte y plena me ha
hecho en la vida
primeros dos años de preparatoria el
único acercamiento que había tenido con
la actuación había sido a través de mi
taller de teatro
si al inicio del último año decidí
inscribirme en una escuela de actuación
de silvia pasquel y al terminar el
primer día lo supe con todo mi cuerpo
esta sensación que había tenido en el
escenario junto a mis primos tocando mi
heart anna lo estaba volviendo a vivir
quedaba de otra más que ser actriz
así que sin falta cada fin de semana mis
abuelos cruzaban conmigo la ciudad y
esperaban todo el día que terminara mis
clases para poder regresar a casa
el camino parecía muy claro muy sencillo
o el último semestre de preparatoria
nuevas decisiones por tomar
y dos dudas preguntas inseguridades
y me dedico a esto me moriré de hambre
prefiero mi estabilidad prefiero
comodidad
hoy a estudiar odontología no mejor voy
a hacer comunicólogas para acercarme un
poco más a lo que quiero del arte
si con un promedio final de 9.92 becas
una para odontología otra para
comunicación debía tomar una decisión
alguna razón decidí meterme a estudiar
una noche antes sobre escuelas que
tuvieran una carrera de actuación y le
encontré las azul azul artes escénicas
argos con una carrera de duración tres
años lo supe
senté a hablar con mi madre con mis
abuelos mis tíos toda la familia
y cuando pienso en ese momento viene a
mí una frase que leí hace poco y que le
dio rumbo a esa conversación
puede que sea un éxito clamoroso puede
que sea un fracaso estrepitoso puede que
ni siquiera llega a nacer
los que hemos cogido este tren tenemos
la voluntad de intentarlo
así que les dije que no tenía idea si va
a funcionar pero que no quería no podía
quedarme con la angustia de saber que lo
pude haber intentado que pasara todo
o que lo intentara y simplemente no
pasará nada
a un lado las becas ellos me miraron
aterrados
pero me dieron todo su apoyo y
contención
el último día de clases en la
preparatoria mi director nos pidió que
escribiéramos en un libro nuestro nombre
que nos íbamos a dedicar y la escuela a
la que habíamos entrado cuando mi
director la leyó volteo a verme con una
sonrisa y me dijo estás equivocando te
vas a morir de hambre yo creo que
deberías dedicarte algo como la
agricultura
o casa azul el primer filtro era una
entrevista y la presentación de un
monólogo se llamaba el ángel mi vida
había tenido un monólogo en mis manos
en mi vida había interpretado uno no
sabía ni siquiera cómo construir un
personaje así que me encerré lo memorice
y lo trabaje lo mejor que pude de
acuerdo a mi intuición
si quieres recuerdo el momento del
monólogo pero recuerdo que estaba muy
nerviosa porque antes algunos habían
entrado y el director les decía en ese
momento si pasaban a la siguiente etapa
o no era un propedéutico
y fue donde por primera vez sentí que mi
mundo se deshacía
director me dijo que no tenía las
herramientas necesarias no podía decirme
en ese momento si quedaba en el
propedéutico o no debía esperar a que
los resultados fueran publicados pero
que él creía que yo no estaba lista
es motivo muchísimo
lo regrese cuando se publicaron los
resultados y no sé por qué razón pero mi
nombre apareció ahí
en ese momento se los juro que me
prometí que iba a dejarlo todo en ese
propedéutico
si me quedé seleccionada en la carrera
en ese momento mi mundo personal mis
creencias mi castillo de cristal se
deshizo
y de construir para después construir me
enfrente a mis demonios
no si cosas en mí sin ese proceso tal
vez me hubiera costado mucho trabajo ver
reconocer aceptar agradecer
los miedos las dudas las frustraciones
eran constantes y el objetivo seguía muy
claro pero mis abuelos siempre estaban
ahí para contenerme y mi madre siempre
estaba del otro lado del teléfono para
sanarme sacudirme y levantarme para
seguir
día de la ceremonia de mi graduación fui
seleccionada para dar unas palabras de
agradecimiento y al finalizar la celia
urquidi en ese entonces directora de
argos comunicación se acercó a mí para
decirme que le gustaba lo que había en
mis palabras y hablaba de mi corazón y
que quizá tenía una oportunidad para mí
así que seguí sus indicaciones y al poco
tiempo me llamaron para audicionar en
una serie en su tercera temporada de
capadocia quede seleccionada
la celia me dio la posibilidad de
conocer otro mundo
otra opción otro rumbo
pues de ese proyecto yo pensé que las
cosas iban a ser más sencillas que más
puertas se abrirían con facilidad
tenía ni idea de todos los obstáculos
que estaban por venir
según años sin trabajar sin saber cómo
de qué manera y qué puertas tocar
en la escuela nadie nos dice algo
primordial de la profesión saber lidiar
con la frustración
nadie nos dice que hacer en los momentos
de espera mientras ocurre algo
nadie nos enseña cómo hacer un casting
cómo abrir puertas cómo abrir caminos
nos dicen que nuestro verdadero trabajo
no es actuar
y no buscar trabajo de actuar termina
siendo un regalo
ellos que te conocen se desconocen
apenas se dan la vuelta y aquellos que
jamás te imaginaste se vuelven tus
aliados
hola no nos da muchas cosas pero también
está en uno buscarlas
recuerdo que un maestro me dijo alguna
vez michi las cartas nunca se equivocan
solo que no siempre ocurren en el
momento que uno desea pero si trabajas
costó mucho trabajo entender que muchas
cosas ni siquiera dependían de mí o de
mi talento
era primordial saber eso
el primer casting que hice después de
haber hecho capadocia fue para un
cortometraje
donde el director me llamó personalmente
después de la audición para decirme que
en mi trabajo había sido maravilloso
pero que desafortunadamente no podía
cambiar a su actor principal
y me dijo que literalmente si me ponía
junto a él me lo comería
así que por ser buena en mi trabajo me
quedé sin el obstáculos de todo tipo
siempre ha sido un reto me senté a crear
estrategias para entrar en el mundo
cinematográfico estrategias para entrar
al mundo de la televisión estrategias
para entrar al mundo del teatro y que
fuera bien remunerado cada seis meses me
sentaba a revisar las estrategias ver
cuáles funcionaban cuáles no ya
modificarlas cada 15 días cada mes
mandaba mi material por todos lados
no sé cómo pero en algún punto las
puertas comenzaron a abrirse
y proyectos comenzaron a llegar
una agencia maravillosa comenzó a
trabajar conmigo
sin darme cuenta el sueño empezaba a
haberse materializado
pese a trabajar con personas que
admiraba desde que era niña y ante la
emoción de estar frente a ellos lo único
que podía hacer era respirar
entregar lo mejor de mí y aprender de
ellas y ellos como mis maestros sobre
todo algo que siempre me ha costado
muchísimo trabajo disfrutar el viaje
eso no pasa tanto tiempo enfocado en que
algo ocurra que cuando ocurre no se
olvide disfrutar
y una serie de cosas de sugerencias que
he vivido a lo largo de mi carrera y que
hoy me encantaría compartirles
los momentos de espera
siempre hay cosas nuevas por aprender
aprende a tocar un instrumento monta a
caballo maneja entrena tu cuerpo entrena
tu espíritu domina un idioma nuevo
nunca nada está de más ser más preparado
este es más oportunidades tendrás
y en algún momento de espera pensé que
no tendría trabajo y me dio la locura
así que decidí meterme a estudiar la
carrera de psicología sin darme cuenta
entre filmaciones campers viajes
madrugadas termine no solo la carrera
sino también la maestría
si renuncié a muchas cosas
pero afortunadamente el trabajo no falto
y aprendí muchas cosas nuevas
casting siempre es una oportunidad
no importa si te quedas o no es una
oportunidad para que te conozcan para
ser visto para mostrar tu trabajo
y directoras y directores de casting con
los que apenas hace nueve años nueve
años después logré obtener una
oportunidad una oportunidad que me ha
llevado a interpretar dos de los
personajes más entrañables en mi vida
hasta el día de hoy
nunca digas que no
sin antes escuchar no sin antes entender
y al lugar y proponer
minimizó es a nadie
mira a quién tienes enfrente a quién
tienes al lado
nunca sabes quién puede ser tu aliado
tienes que moverte muévete el lugar
nunca es una limitante busca investiga
prepárate
pero muévete nunca dejes nada al azar
sobre todo por sobre todas las cosas de
fe constancia disciplina
plantea estrategias pruebas cosas nuevas
no sé quién es parte de ese mundo al que
quieres pertenecer investiga a la gente
con la que quieres trabajar
lee en los programas de mano quédate a
ver los créditos ve teatro vive el
teatro infórmate
nunca te quedes parado
en el genio y hacer realidad sus deseos
no es un trabajo sencillo
es un trabajo agotador
trabajo del actor a veces hay más
trabajo detrás de él el que se imaginan
y del que se respeta
nos recuerda en la pasión con la que
haces tu trabajo si es importante si
cambia la vida de alguien de entrada
cambia la tuya
solo estoy frente a ustedes para
agradecerles la oportunidad
he tenido para soñar y para volar
si tienes un sueño una meta no importa
cuál sea la meta por los objetivos y
trabaja cada segundo cada minuto cada
hora cada instante
ya tengas que renunciar a muchas cosas y
se sientas las que ya has aprendido
nos sirven pero las vas a tener que
volver a aprender
sobre todo hay una frase que leí hace
poco y me encanta
cuando te canses aprende a descansar no
a darte por vencido
cuando llegas
esa sonrisa de satisfacción y plenitud
en el rostro es la paz más embriagante
que se puede tener en la vida
favor nunca dejen nada al azar
hace años minatitlán veracruz
pero del 2020
el nacimiento
[Aplausos]